[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pour un débat sur un sujet
tabou inflammable l'héritage le
patrimoine privé des français provient
aux deux tiers de l'héritage d'après
l'économiste nicolas frémaux deux tiers
de leurs richesses ont donc été hérités
un tiers seulement a été gagnée dans les
années soixante dix et l inverse on
pouvait encore acheté un appartement à
paris en travaillant aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir acheter un appartement à paris
il faut en avoir déjà un alors
régulièrement on entend parler
d'augmenter les frais de succession ou
de supprimer carrément l'héritage mais
rien de plus impopulaire car tout le
monde trouve normal quand on a bien
réussi dans la vie d'en faire profiter
ses enfants pour en débattre nous avons
donc invité frédéric douet vous êtes
professeur de droit fiscal à
l'université de rouen vous êtes l'auteur
du précis de droit fil qui est plus
précis de droit fiscal de la famille
chez lexisnexis et de l'anti manuel de
psychologie fiscale technique de plus
maison des contribuables centre où les
faire crier c'est paru chez enrique vous
c'est plutôt vive les joue à mort
l'héritage plutôt vivre l'héritage mais
comme vous le disais c'est une matière
hautement inflammable surtout d'un point
de vue fiscal
voilà nicolas frémaux vous êtes maître
de conférences en économie à
l'université paris ii spécialisé dans
l'économie de la famille vous êtes
l'auteur des nouveaux héritiers au seuil
vous c'est plutôt à mort l'héritage que
vivre l'héritage
non je pense que vu les les français
doivent pouvoir transmettre leur
héritage mais c'est vrai que l'impôt
aujourd'hui d'être révisés de manière
limitée en tout cas ces inégalités qui
viennent de l'héritage alors comment
sont justement sur ce sujet faut-il
augmenter les droits de succession on en
reparle régulièrement pourquoi
faudrait-il les augmenté d'après vous
je pense qu'il faut un concours parle
d'augmentation faut bien voir de qui on
parle je pense que les augmenter pour
tout le monde un nouveau ce n'est pas
forcément souhaitable économiquement et
ce serait justement assez compliqué mon
avis politiquement à faire passer comme
comme réforme parce que vous avez je
pense on parlait pas mal mais en
attachement très fort des français à
leur patrimoine alors leurs enfants en
fait de le transmettre à leurs enfants
dont taxer tout le monde de la même
manière c'est clairement pas une bonne
une bonne solution c'est ce que fait
l'info aujourd'hui c'est justement c
passé c'est vraiment de taxer manière
progressive donc de toucher plus
fortement les plus grosses successions
et de laisser libre des transmises les
successions les plus il est le plus
faible ou l'éducation moyenne tous les
ponts mais la barre je pense que c'est
un impôt aujourd'hui qui fonctionne pas
très bien qui peut créer quand même des
inégalités très importante et ce qu'on
voit justement c'est que l'impôt que sur
le français l'amap aux français qui sur
le papier est un impôt qui est très
progressif n'arrive pas à juguler
justement ce sera autour de l'héritage
qui était si confiscatoire on aurait pas
aujourd'hui ce sera au tour de
l'héritage et des situations vraiment
malade inégalités très fort du point de
vue du point de vue de l'héritage alors
sur le plan fiscal c'est ma spécialité
phase avec dos et qu'est ce qui se passe
même corriger un tiers des français
méritent rien un tiers hérite de moins
de 8500 euros et un tiers hérite du
reste donc plus de 8500 euros et ça va
jusqu'à des fortunes considérables
sur cet ensemble 90% ne sont donc taxés
sur rien il ya 10% qui payent l'impôt
sur les successions effectivement une
faible une faible proportion de
contribuables français qui effectivement
ne s'acquittent de ce qu'on appelle des
droits de succession on parle de droits
de mutation à titre gratuit qui couvrent
à la fois les droits de donation et de
droits de succession donc là on part les
droits de succession pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur dans la loi de
finances pour 2021 les droits de
succession pour l'année sont chiffrées à
12 milliards d'euros et les droits de
donation à 3 milliards d'euros
feria ça veut dire que c'est un bar
rapport au budget de l'état c'est
quelque chose
l'impôt sur la fortune c'est 2 milliards
la tva si on est dans les ordres de
grandeur ses 142 milliards l'impôt sur
le revenu 92 milliards et l'impôt sur
les sociétés 62 milliards oui on parle
de quelque chose qui est au budget de
l'état certes est important mais ça
reste quand même assez anecdotique la
particularité aussi de la france et que
en moyenne dans les pays de l' ocde le
les droits de mutation à titre gratuit
représente 0 34 % du pib pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur et il ya
quatre pays dans le monde enfin parmi
les membres de l' ocde qui ce qui se
distingue en ayant un taux supérieur 1 %
on a le japon la corée la belgique et la
france en france ça représente 2 93% des
recettes fiscales toujours lorsqu'on lit
la dernière loi de finances donc c'est
déjà quelque chose d'assez levé par deux
internes mais il ya en belgique alors
pourquoi est-ce que tant de gens
français fortunés vont s'installer en
belgique soit disant parce que les
droits de succession leur sont
favorables alors parce qu'en belgique il
n'ya pas de l'impôt sur la fortune c'est
ça il n'ya pas l'impôt sur la fortune
effectivement c'est taxer plus mais on
en a rajouté le loto le tarif des droits
de succession veut pas dire grand chose
parce que vous avez énormément de bien
qu'ils sont qui sont exonérés vous en
avez d'autres qui font l'objet d'un
abattement et puis vous avez des
abattements qui sont plus ou moins
importants en fonction de votre lien de
parenté qui existe ou pas avec le
successeur ou avec le donateur donc tout
ça fait que parler uniquement du taux
des droits de succession c'est pas
quelque chose qui est vraiment très
révélateur
nicolas femme oh oui je vois je suis
tout à fait d'accord c'est un impôt qui
évidemment complexe parce qu'on est fait
il ya plein de règles en fonction d'une
lame du patrimoine que vous allez donner
est ce que c'est l'assurance vie est ce
que c'est l'immobilier est ce que tu
t'es vue financier les règles vont pas
être les mêmes et on ait fait quelque
chose qui est très important en france
et qu'on retrouve aussi dans nos pays
c'est ce qui vient des 10 et le côté le
lien familial en fait qui va qui va
beaucoup jouer ou si vous transmettez un
conjoint ou un enfant ou à quelqu'un
d'extérieur la famille le taux pratiqué
les abattements justement pratiquer
votre complètement différent et donc si
on la joue sur des moyennes mais nouveau
d'accord c'est compliqué d'interpréter
des moyennes mais par exemple le taux
d'imposition entre des conjoints qui
sont pacsés ou mariés scène 2 0% depuis
depuis 2007 le taux moyen entre parents
et enfants avec à nouveau des très
grandes différences mais en moyenne 100
m 2 2% donc beaucoup plus faible que la
csg que d'impôts et à linverse le taux
pratiqué entre apple en ligne
collatérale donc en dehors du conjoint
survivant ou des enfants c'est 25% c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui la somme qu'ils
payent beaucoup d'impôts en france
beaucoup d'impôt sur les successions ça
peut être les très grosses successions
c'est surtout en fait les personnes qui
décèdent sans enfant qui représenterait
10 % des montants transmis en fait plus
de la moitié des recettes fiscales vous
allez un système qui est là qui joue
très fortement en fonction du lien du
lien de parenté et ça s'est accrue
depuis les années 50 en fait on a
vraiment une politique en france on
retrouve aussi dans d'autres pays on
n'est pas allé et ça va faire ça en
favorisant complètement donc les
conjoints survivants et l'enfant par
rapport à par rapport aux autres
transmission qu'on peut mais justement
alors là on est mauvais dans au coeur du
problème c'est à dire que si tout le
monde ne trouve que l'héritage c'est
formidable c'est parce que c'est
véritablement considéré comme une valeur
familiale transmettre ses biens à ses
enfants c'est considéré comme comme
vertueux les transmettre à des amis par
exemple c'est mal on se souvient de l'
affaire bettencourt quand eliane
bettencourt donnait des millions à
françois-marie banier tout le monde
était scandalisé quand françoise
bettencourt la fille de liliane
bettencourt à récupérer l'argent tout le
monde a applaudi
alors que françoise bettencourt était
infiniment plus riche que françois-marie
banier mais françois marie-banier
c'était de l'argent mal gagné alors que
françoise bettencourt et ses enfants qui
aujourd'hui je vis de la fortune de
liliane bettencourt c'est tout à fait
normal on est comme ça nous les français
oui un peu spéciaux de sa propre à la
france avait justement plainte une
explication pour pour le rejet justement
de l'impôt sur les successions c'est en
grande partie justement ces valeurs
familiales ses valeurs morales en disant
mais justement on ne devrait pas taxer
jeu dans les bacs des parents
l'altruisme des parents pendant toute
leur vie parce qu'ils ont voilà ils ont
acquis des fois d'un patrimoine très
limitée des fois beaucoup plus
importants et donc on devrait pas leur
ne voit pas accès tout ça c'est un délit
mot qui est mise en avant très fortement
mais si on essaye d'expliquer aussi
l'impopularité d'un post on se rend
compte c'est une partie non négligeable
en fait qui vient du fait que les
français comprennent pas très bien cet
impôt donc ça veut pas dire que les
français sont suffisants du tout c'est
vrai que c'est un impôt comme on vient
de le dire qui est très compliqué qu'on
rencontre a beaucoup moins souvent dans
sa vie que la tva que l'impôt sur le
revenu que la taxe d'habitation par
exemple que vous avez tous les ans
manière très fréquente et ce qui a été
montré notamment dans une expérience en
souhaite céder que vous donner des
informations
vraies informations sur aujourd'hui
voilà qui payent l'impôt qui reçoit
l'héritage qu'est ce que ça veut dire en
fait les gens changent d'avis donc quand
ils se rendent compte pour résumer comme
ça que qui vont pas être touché par les
impôts bas en fait vous pouvez avoir une
adhésion beaucoup plus grande dès
l'instant que vous avez cet enfant ça
c'est assez important et ce qu'on sait
en france et qui est une très grande
voix sur estimation faite de l'impôt
donc au delà des valeurs des valeurs
familiales il ya aussi d'autres
explications à cette impopularité de
si on leur disait aux français que 90%
des successions n'ouvre aucun impôt ne
sont pas taxées il serait pour qu'on
augmente
le bol impôts par définition c'est
toujours la peau qui est payé par
l'autre
mais c'est un peu plus complexe que ça
parce que
nicolas frémaux le coc aussi bien que
moi on a par exemple en matière de
transmission d'entreprises
ce qu'on appelle les pactes dutreil qui
permettent de faire échapper les
entreprises à l'impôt sur les
successions ou sur les droits de
donation à concurrence de 75 % de leur
valeur ça c'est pour paco le tissu
économique français c'est niet mais en
creux ça veut dire quand même que le
législateur en incitant ce dispositif
reconnaît que dans certains cas le taux
marginal est beaucoup trop élevé sinon
il s'est abattu en 2 75% n'aurait pas
lieu d'être et alors vous parliez de du
cas de la suède le cas de la suède est
intéressant parce que en europe au sein
de l'union européenne il ya six états
qui ne connaissent pas les droits de
successions notamment la suède qui les a
supprimées en 2004 alors à l'époque ça
avait suscité débat aussi passionné
qu'en france et en 2004 dont on a su
être supprimé les droits de succession
et sait tout sur tout et entre 2004 et
2016 on s'est aperçu que les recettes
fiscales de la suède avait bondi de 50%
pourquoi parce que tout un tas de
contribuables qui s'était exilé pour des
raisons fiscales n'y a pas que les
français qui partent en belgique
manifestement les suédois les bugs aussi
quitté la suède ou regagner la suède ont
fait bondir les recettes fiscales est
d'ailleurs dans le même temps la part de
la pression fiscale dont le pib je crois
de mémoire est passée de 51% à 44 % mais
en même temps ça a creusé les inégalités
oui mais
alors là on va peut-être avoir deux avis
divergent mais c'est peut-être aussi le
but avec mon contradicteur
la lutte pour les inégalités pour moi
cette histoire de redistribution déjà ne
joue qu'à la marge parce que même si
vous preniez tout
la totalité des héritages je ne pense
pas qu'on réussir est qu à combler
complètement les inégalités ça je pense
que c'est une ville esprits et puis
cette histoire d'impôt redistributif
finalement ne corrige les inégalités
qu'à la marge elle ne corrige pas les
racines du mal qui sont l'âge les
niveaux de formation le milieu peau
socio professionnelles etc il ya tout un
taux de tout un tas d'autres facteurs
qui font que on peut pas corriger comme
ça de but en blanc les inégalités on
peut les atténuer la marge grâce à
l'impôt et c'est tout à fait c'est tout
à fait normal et justifié à mon sens
mais ça reste quand même une
modification à la marche il ya des
constantes d'inégalités c'est pas des
inégalités dans l'absolu mais c'était le
ce que cité en introduction de cette
émission la génération de mon père quand
elle gagnait bien sa vie pouvait
s'acheter un appartement à paris
ma génération c'est devenu très
difficile
pour acheter un appartement à paris il
faut déjà en avoir un il faut en avoir
hérité un qu'on peut revendre pour en
acheter un plus grand accès pour ceux
qui se contentent de l'argent qu'il
gagne c'est pas de l'argent qu'ils
héritent c'est quasiment devenu
impossible c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
effectivement mais bon après reste à
savoir si en surtaxant effectivement les
grosses successions ci vous permettra
tout le monde s'y sent rien n'est fait
effectivement si on abolit l'héritage
les prix l'immobilier à paris dégringole
oh ça c'est sûr mais ça peut aussi faire
fuir
beaucoup de continuer à très forte une
hors de france en relais et ce qui reste
ce sont toujours ceux qui
est au moins ils ont revendu appartement
sa frappe être votre bonheur nicolas
frémaux
oui je ne suis pas en partie d'accord en
parties en désaccord
c'est normal sur le premier point en
effet il ya plein de sources aux
inégalités et l'impôt dont il ya
plusieurs types d'impôts si on souhaite
ce qui explique et aussi la baisse de la
pression fiscale c'est la suppression si
l'équivalent liés c'est fou juste avant
en fait cette suppression de l'impôt sur
les successions c'est aussi parce qu'ils
étaient faits au début du mandat par
exemple de d'emmanuel macron c'est aussi
le fait que les revenus de la propriété
donc les dividendes ont été taxés avant
étaient taxés de manière progressive
sont devenus taxer de manière
proportionnelle donc ce qui se passait
en france avec 7 sept aps la taxe donc
sur aussi revenu à céder plus beaucoup
plus important chez neil que les
successions voilà la baisse s'explique
en partie aussi par d'autres éléments
c'est le premier bon et après on écrit
donc
une
clinique estimé ce qu'on a vu dans
certains pays
unis par exemple vous avez eu des
politiques fiscales qui ont vraiment
varier du tout au tout pendant 50 ans
des années 30 aux années
1930 aux années 1980 vous a vu alors
d'abolition de l'héritage mais un
plafonnement de l'héritage chaque le
taux maximal supérieur donc en france
juste pour pour expliquer on n'a pas
encore évoqué mais au delà d'un certain
montant vous allez payer un taux qui
s'accroît c'est la progressivité de
l'impôt donc en france entre parents et
enfants au delà de 1,8 million vous
commencez à payer 45 % d'impôts c'est
souvent un taux qu'on va qu'on va mettre
en avant aux états unis ce taux maximum
supérieur qui s'appliquait à partir de
succession élevé il a été pendant très
longtemps autour de 90% au-delà de ce
seuil la ont plafonné comprenez
quasiment tous donc c'est deux fois et
hop y avait en france et ce taux là il
était impliqué pendant 50 ans donc c'est
pas juste une lubie d'un candidat
démocrate ça a été renouvelée par des
présidents républicains ensuite pendant
une cinquantaine d'années est serré guen
qui a mis fin et vous avez lu sur cette
période à la même chose sur les salaires
sur les sur les revenus donc vraiment un
impôt donc très fort très progressif qui
plafonnait les revenus les héritages et
vous avez une croissance très forte dans
la période des inégalités qui ont très
fortement baissé on ne peut pas dire
qu'elle était nulle après ça parce que
on essaye à d'autres facteurs expliquent
des inégalités il va voir là j'en ai
fait votre niveau de formation de la
chance aussi évidemment mais sakho est
un outil très puissant est ce qu'on a vu
aux etats-unis c'est que depuis les
années 80 le mécanisme inverse s'est
passé on est très forte réduction de
l'impôt sur les successions notamment
aujourd'hui d'impôts il pas supprimé
mais les pays car quasiment plus
personne vous pouvez transmettre jusqu'à
12 millions de dollars sans payer un
centime d'impôts aux états unis est ce
qu'on a vu c'est une évolution désigner
très rapide et une baisse aussi la
croissance économique quelque chose qui
a eu un effet bénéfique pour tout le
pays sur huit seulement dont on parle en
fait aux états unis maintenant on a 40
ans de recul on le retrouve pas donc il
ya bien il ya bien aussi un effet un
effet assez important de l'imposture
aussi l'efficacité économique et pas
seulement sur les inégalités françois
dauré
oui effectivement le montant que le
montant de l'abattement en ligne directe
c'est-à-dire entre parents à notre
enfant et enfants aux etats unis les
d'un million d'euros en france une éco
200000 euros donc déjà on a un écart
ouais c'est du simple c'est x 10 donc
c'est que c'est quelque chose c'est
quelque chose d'énorme après en vous
écoutant je me disais mais finalement
est-ce que les droits de succession il a
droit de donation sont pas des impôts
qui sont datés finalement des impôts un
peu du 19e est ce qu'il faudrait pas
rebâtir entièrement notre notre système
fiscal ça j'en suis entièrement
convaincu
notamment et là je pense que nous allons
nous nous rejoindre avec nicolas frémaux
pour instituer un véritable revenu
universel
qui existe déjà selon moi parce que
quand on regarde le montant des sommes
qui sont distribués je crois que de
mémoire ses 742 milliards d'euros par an
mais sauf que ça se divise en une
myriade dette sociale d'être familiale
de crédit d'impôt davantage fils cause
en tout genre est ce qui serait pas plus
simple finalement deux tours fondre pour
avoir un véritable revenu universel qui
sera attribué à chaque français de sa
naissance jusqu'à son décès revenu
universel qui peut être
financé assez facilement par une micro
taxe sur les transactions sur les
paiements scripturaux
les paiements scripturaux pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur c'est
environ 28 500 milliards d'euros par an
en france donc si on raisonne sur une
taxe de 2 % ça permet de dégager plus de
550 milliards d'euros par an et donc
dans le même temps on supprime les
cotisations sociales les cotisations
salariales les prélèvements sociaux on
peut supprimer aussi les tout ce qu'ils
lisent tout ce qui plombe les
entreprises françaises c'est à dire les
impôts de production et puis si on est
un petit peu plus énervé on peut
supprimer aussi les droits de donation
et de succession vous voyez ça laisse
quand même beau stade autre débat
c'était une autre des perspectives au
fond
françoise bettencourt non seulement
rites et de liliane bettencourt sa
fortune mais en plus tout serait le
revenu et toucherait effectivement le
revenu universel parce que si elle ne le
touchais pas il ne serait pas
universelle peu
après sur cette histoire d'un revenu
universel je sais que ce n'est pas le
sujet mais il ya quelques divergences à
la marge est ce que tout le monde doit
le toucher ou pas prendre à l'avenir les
banques n'a eu ce débat ici mais alors
moi j'en ai un autre débat c'est mais
plus pour nicolas frémaux
est-ce qu'il est morale de demander à
à
payer des droits de succession sur des
biens pour lesquels on a déjà il
qu'imposer
c'est à dire que les parents ont été
imposées sur l'argent qu'ils ont gagné
ils ont été imposées sur les biens la
plupart du temps qu'ils ont acquis et
ils vont être encore imposé au moment
ils veulent les transmettre à ses
enfants alors en force et en fait c'est
un impôt sur la mort qu'on leur demande
de payer oui je sais pas si c'est
souvent comme ça c'est un impôt sur la
mort mais après l'argument aussi de la
double imposition de payer un impôt sur
quelque chose qui a déjà été imposé en
fait on le retrouve dans tout le système
français donc c'est quasi impossible
d'avoir quelque chose qui taxait une
seule fois la tva par exemple vous allez
acheter une baguette de pain avec votre
salaire qui a déjà été imposé et vous
pour payer de la tva sur le bien avec
ton cadeau un revenu qui a déjà été
imposé des taxes foncières c'est
exactement la même chose on entend par
cet argument là il peut s'y tient il
tient pour tous les impôts et on met à
battre tout le système qui serait en
fait un argument qui peut se tenir qui
peut être pendue qui va bien au delà
finalement du seul impôt sur les
successions après sur la dimension
morale de l'ain pour y passer c'est un
impôt qui étaient débattus bien avant
les économistes qui était un sujet
vraiment disputes au sein des
philosophes avec des situations vraiment
très très différentes sur les chaussures
des sur des idées voilà des positions
très différentes avec dans des villes et
philosophe libéraux qui étaient pas du
tout pour une remise en cause en de la
propriété privée mais qui disait que une
grosse différence entre détenir des
biens tout à fait le droit de tenir des
biens mais les transmettre sa mine en
fait la cohésion sociale parce que des
personnes vont se retrouver avec une
position très élevé dans la société sans
l'avoir mérité et pour une société
fonctionne et pour que les gens adhèrent
à l'impôt une cohésion sociale devrait
justement renouveler les élites à chaque
génération et donc il y avait vraiment
des arguments philosophiques derrière
sur la moralité donc les économistes ont
des arguments aussi les juristes aussi
mais en fait c'est une question qui va
bien d'autres l'un des seuls économistes
on est clairement c'est un débat qui
doit toucher questions sociales et nous
droit évidemment immense et mais je vais
vous en pause et d'ailleurs a besoin de
ces questions je les ai prévu dans la
deuxième partie mais je vous laisse
réagir frédéric
oui oui effectivement c'est un débat
sans fin et c'est une critique est
récurrente
lorsqu'on parle avec les gens de toutes
catégories sociales qui disent y compris
ce qui d'ailleurs ne paieront jamais de
droits de succession qui disent mais on
comprend pas finalement parce que nous
avons travaillé nous avons été imposées
pour ce revenu surtout prélèvements
sociaux csg crds
après nous avons dû payer de la tva
lorsque nous avons consommé des impôts
locaux taxe d'habitation enfin qui va
peut-être disparaître et puis taxes
foncières s'ils ont la chance d'être
propriétaire et puis le jour nous décès
dont on nous demande à nouveau de payer
de l'impôt mais c'est notre système
fiscal et ça rejoint ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure qui fait que à
priori un certain nombre d'imposition
sont datés il faudrait refondre tout ça
et elle et les chiffres que je devenais
en introduction de cette émission qui
sont les vôtres nicolas frémaux
aujourd'hui deux tiers du patrimoine
privé des français deux tiers de leurs
richesses sont des richesses hérité un
tiers seulement a été gagné et une chose
d'un peu choquant là dedans
oui on peut le voir on peut le voir
comme étant chaud quand on s'attaque à
une grosse différence entre l'image
qu'on a une société méritocratique sur
le discours qui est menée par tous les
partis en fait ça s'est confondu en par
les partis de droite et les partis de
gauche aussi en disant dans aujourd'hui
en france les inégalités sont mérités on
voit très bien que c'est laid c'est en
tout cas d'offre d'un pan du patrimoine
n'est pas le cas et on voit aussi que du
point de vue du niveau scolaire c'est un
autre sujet
notre situation potentielle là dessus on
voit très bien c'est un gros problème
enfin on sait qu'aujourd'hui le
classement pisa sous tous les angles
mais en france où il
met là mais la france comme un très
mauvais élèves en terme de reproduction
justement des inégalités entre
générations donc en france on a vraiment
vraiment des mutations des inégalités
qui sont très importantes tant sur le
niveau des inégalités qui ont un peu
augmenté depuis depuis une vingtaine
d'années mais surtout quatre sur la
nature des inégalités on a des
inégalités aujourd'hui qui sont de plus
en plus en fait hériter d'une génération
à l'autre et de moins en moins mérité
parlée par les individus et donc ça
c'est une vraie question c'est un vrai
choix de société si on veut supprimer
demain l'impôt sur les impôts sur les
successions lorsque ça va ravir à une
grande partie des français qui s'y
opposent mais on va à nouveau avoir des
effets sur les inégalités et sur la
nature des inégalités très très
importante donc oui ce retour l'héritage
il peut être vu comme étant assez assez
choquant de ce point de vue là est ce
qu'il n'ya pas quelque chose de choquant
un peu là dedans on croit voir une
dation de gagneur de propriétaires de
type qui ont fait leur vie en fait non
ils ont juste hérité l'argent du papa
ouais mais bon c'est aussi le signe de
la paupérisation de la population
française est aussi ce phénomène
et puis là on parle de moyenne on fait
donc il faut pas faire de peut-être d'un
certain nombre de cas particulier des
généralités il ya aussi ça mais il
faudrait effectivement revoir mais que
nicolas frey moi de le faire beaucoup
plus en détail toutes les toutes les
statistiques pour voir effectivement où
se situe le point de rupture autre
statistique aujourd'hui on hérite à plus
de 50 ans c'était à 30 ans il ya encore
c'est pas 50 ou 60 en hérite et à 30 ans
aujourd'hui on hérite à 50 ou 60 ans
c'est pas du tout la même chose quand on
hérite ça soit 50 60 ans ce n'est pas
une motivation on se lance pas dans un
dans un business quand on est un paysan
et qu'on hérite 50 60 ans par la
retraite effectivement le bouleversement
de la philosophie déjà je fais que les
français de plus en plus tard y compris
un âge où ils sont déjà à la retraite
donc a priori lorsqu'on est à la
retraite on est plus poussée d'un vent
très très violent donc ça ne favorise
pas une gestion très dynamique des
patrimoines et les législateurs la ville
avait bien compris puisqu'il ya encore
quelques années il existait des
réductions sur le montant des droits de
donation qui étaient liées à l'âge du
donateur donc l'idée était simple plus
vous donniez eto'o avons généralement
vos enfants plus la réduction était
importante et ça pouvait atteindre
jusqu'à 50 % de réduction donc ça selon
moi ça favorisait une véritable gestion
dynamique des patrimoines sont incités
français a donné ce qu'ils peuvent bien
évidemment à donner régulièrement leurs
enfants notamment les chefs d'entreprise
et cetera et cetera donc ça ça dynamise
et la gestion des pâtés mal
malheureusement ces réductions de droits
de donation était supprimée sur l'autel
de la rigueur budgétaire dans les années
de mémoire 2011 2012 et depuis il existe
des exonérations ont parlé tout à
l'heure des pactes dutreil mais c'est
beaucoup plus ciblées beaucoup plus
contraignant d'un point de vue d'un
point de vue fiscal étant précisé aussi
que puisque j'évoque les pactes dutreil
que les pactes dutreil sont devenus un
monument de droit bureaucratique
qu'enfin il suffit de prendre le
d'ouvrir le code général des impôts et
d'en garder l'article 757 granby grand
c'est pour les obsédés textuels et vous
verrez que c'est quelque chose de très
contraignant qui sans cesse et modifié
est compliqué c'est quasiment une
spécialité à part entière les pactes
dutreil donc ça pose de vrais problèmes
au niveau de la lisibilité de l'impôt ça
c'est ce qui permet aux entreprises de
rester entre les mains d'une famille
plutôt que d'être dissoute assez bas ont
fait une pause et puis on va reparler
justement
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur l'héritage avec
nicolas frémaux qui est maître de
conférences en économie à l'université
paris ii est l'auteur des nouveaux
héritiers au seuil et frédéric douet qui
est professeur de droit fiscal à
l'université de rouen c'est l'auteur de
lentilles manuel de psychologie fiscal
sous titres et technique de plus maison
des contribuables sans troller faire
crier chez hendrick on parlait de de ces
abattements qui permettent de que les
entreprises soient transmises et que
leur capital soient pas dispersées
au moment de la mort de leurs
propriétaires ou de leur fondateur donc
on protège la l'héritage industriel
pourquoi ne protégeront pas l'héritage
quand on hérite des droits d'astérix et
obélix ou ou des droits de tintin
pourquoi là on est davantage
taxées pour sa part est injuste pourquoi
suis-je hérite d'une maison on me taxe
davantage que ses virées du générique
pardon d'une usine c'est ce que je vous
ai tout à l'heure en creux ça veut dire
que le taux est beaucoup trop élevé
lorsque vous transmettre une entreprise
c'est pour ça que législateur a institué
c'est pas que ces pactes dutreil et la
philosophie de ce dispositif c'est la
volonté de maintenir le tissu économique
français pour éviter que les entreprises
françaises soient déposés au décès de
leur
de leurs dirigeants donc ça s'est butée
effectivement on peut se dire à partir
de là pourquoi est ce que le chef
d'entreprise peut bénéficier de ce
dispositif et pourquoi comme vous le
disiez si j'hérite je suis l'ayant droit
d'ester l'artiste ou d'actes mamba quoi
est ce que je serai davantage accès mais
ça ce sont des questions de politique
fiscale des arbitrages qui sont faits
par le législateur nicolas frémaux oui
d'où toutes les niches fiscales en effet
le pacte dutreil en ayant lyonnais
beaucoup d'autres sur les assurances vie
à chaque fois ils vont partir d'une
bonne intuition var après qu'on peut
justement discuter mais à un des
problèmes en tête de ces niches là c'est
qu'elles sont très peu évaluées donc à
nouveau ne pas taxer de bas trop taxer
les entreprises en effet ça peut
permettre évidemment de transmettre le
bien aux enfants et surtout plein
d'entreprises familiales aujourd'hui
pour les agriculteurs par exemple il ya
des problèmes pour trouver des
repreneurs donc à favoriser la reprise
par les enfants c'est ça peut être une
bonne solution ou pas forcément mais en
fait le problème c'est de voir aussi
qu'est ce que ça implique derrière est
ce que les héritiers sont les mieux à
même pour gérer l'entreprise et les
évaluations qui ont été faites notamment
au danemark sur l'impôt sur les
successions montrer qu'elle s'est
souvent fait l'héritier faisait moins
bien que le fondateur donc ça veut pas
dire évidemment qu'il faut taxer les
entreprises comme les autres bien ça
veut dire que derrière faire des cadeaux
fiscaux qui peut être assez important
pour être sûr que ça marche en fait que
c'est efficace derrière au delà de la
dimension morale de la transmission de
l'entreprise donc si d'un côté vous vous
avez une perte fiscale soit une perte de
recettes fiscales parce que vous faites
des ce cadeau fiscal est important et
derrière l'entreprise fait faillite et
que vous devez débourser les allocations
chômage pour robert
peyrillou à dire les les employés double
perte pour vous donc voilà ce qu'il
faudrait faire c'est vraiment peut-être
à chiner ces pactes là entre les évaluer
beaucoup plus systématiquement
rester sur l'idée c'est très important
de transmettre une entreprise mais là le
pacte dutreil qui s'applique à les
entreprises quasiment de la même manière
même si ça a été évoqué cette manière
très complexe faut que ce soit faut que
ce soit évalué c'est la même chose pour
les oeuvres d'art qui sont protégés on
peut se demander pourquoi pour les
assurances vie au 6e rang belge très
importante qui réduisent très fortement
en fait la facture fiscale au temps où
la distribution donc là on a évoqué
plusieurs fois le baril mlle
l'abattement de 100000 euros vente et
celle de sa d'abattement là il est
beaucoup plus important parce que à
nouveau pour les grosses successions va
passer par d'autres types de 2,2
d'optimisation fiscale et vous plus
seuls les seuls cent mille euros sont
une partie finalement de dubaï quand
vous parlez des oeuvres d'art vous
faites allusion à la dation par exemple
oui c'est ça ben brik et plusieurs
mécanismes et je pense que mon collègue
juristes en se rasant détails et ça
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus que moi mais
là il ya eu de tout un tas de 2,2 de
moyens d'exonérer certains types
d'oeuvres à nouveau pour les oeuvres
d'art on peut considérer que ça part
d'une bonne idée de conserver les arts
les oeuvres d'art en france et ça peut
être très bien mais il faut évaluer à
qui ça profite vraiment qu'ils qui
profitent dénicher un des problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on n'a pas des
statistiques assez détaillés pour dire
qu'ils héritent de quoi qui paye quoi et
soit donc les dernières données
disponibles qu'on a date de 2010 donc
tous les constats que je fais dans mon
livre et sur lesquelles se reposent des
chercheurs ils ont déjà plus de dix ans
aujourd'hui et quand vous demandez à
bercy pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas des
données plus précises merci vous dire il
faut encore attendre quelques années
avant d'avoir des données précises donc
juste sur les éléments de constat même
si on la prend on n'est pas d'accord sur
justement pu faire de l'impôt et sur les
éléments de constat aujourd'hui en
france il ya un gros problème d'accès à
l'information est donc évidemment
surtout si michalak qui en profite
quelles sont les conséquences qui les
paient alors la dation pour le rappeler
ça aurait été inventé pour picasso
d'ailleurs
qui était donc en france et c'est ça
consiste à pouvoir payer une partie des
enfin la totalité des droits de
succession en oeuvre d'art dans le cas
de l'héritage picasso il y avait
tellement d'oeuvre que s'il n'y avait
pas eu ça le prix du picasso se serait
écroulé il aurait été vendu à l'encan
ils se seraient dispersés partout là en
fait les a été versé à l'état en oeuvre
d'art ça a permis d'ouvrir le musée
picasso mais ça veut dire que c'est
l'état qui choisit en premier les
oeuvres qu'il va prendre ce ne sont pas
les héritiers qui disent qu'ils en
voulaient c'est ça non c'est l'état qui
prend et qui dit aux héritiers on vous
laisse ça on peut quand même lui
suggérer de prendre ce loft plus tôt que
les autres mais bon
mais on peut on peut essayer d'avoir sa
part enfin ça vous paraît la dation là
aussi on
ça semble sain comme oui ça semble
simple puisque effectivement ça permet
de garder en france un certain nombre de
bien des trésors nationaux des oeuvres
d'art de grande qualité je dirais puis
de va mettre sur le marché non plus
plein d'oeuvre comme ça d'un seul coup
tu perdrais de leur valeur par une
occasion oui effectivement mais puis ça
permet aussi de votre devoir ensuite ses
oeuvres dans des dans des musées donc ça
profite au plus grand nombre donc c'est
très bien à une époque où les buses et
en plus les moyens d'acheter les oeuvres
souvent sont solides et son français
remontera sur les raisons bien sûr quand
vous avez écrit nicolas frémaux les
nouveaux héritiers ils sont comment ces
nouveaux héritiers par rapport aux
anciens justement créé que en quoi le
système
aujourd'hui vous semble perverti
et on pas les lady une différence
majeure non l'a déjà évoqué donc j'ai
pas revenir dessus c'est différence
d'âge où on habite aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus tard parce qu'on vit beaucoup plus
vieux ça parle comme d'une bonne
nouvelle mais évidemment vérité à 50 ans
60 ans plutôt qu'à 20 ou 25 et ça change
vraiment la donne ensuite à un élément
important c'est donc cette dimension
inégalitaire on retrouve aujourd'hui des
inégalités qui sont très marqués en fait
du point de vue du point de vue de
l'héritage on peut avoir l'impression en
fait quand quand on parle aujourd'hui
que à nouveau qu on est dans une société
mérite rock méritocratique et c'est
assez trompeur mais même quand on évoque
ce retour de l'héritage on peut avoir
l'impression que la figure du rentier
par exemple quelque chose qui
appartiendrait vraiment au passé au
roman de balzac de maupassant etc sauf
qu'aujourd'hui on fait cette figure du
rand si elle revient vraiment donc c'est
pas les mêmes personnes un nouveau cd
personne qui est vérité plus tard mais
si on fait des calculs donc c'est basé
en partie sur des stimulations à nouveau
étant données les données les données
qu'on a mais pour les générations nées
dans les années 70 et 80 on s'attend à
ce que il ya environ dix est 10% fait de
ces générationnel qui sont des rentiers
donc le rentier qu'est ce que ça veut
dire on peut définir de pas mal de
manière c'est des personnes qui vont
recevoir en héritage et en donation plus
que toute une vie de travail donc si
vous reprenez le salaire moyen sur toute
une vie donc plusieurs millions d'euros
passée des personnes qui avoue recevoir
donc plus que toute une vie de travail
donc là on parle pas de quelqu'un mais
recevoir un bel appartement à paris
c'est plus que ça et donc ses
personnages représenter 10% de dire de
ma génération des personnes qui sont
mais dans les années 80 donc on est loin
du cas de figure je demande qu'on
l'évoqué d'ailleurs le cas bettencourt
ou dégoût des familles qui sont dans le
classement ça va être une grosse partie
de la population est à nouveau cette
année un impact très fort sur les
inégalités donc on n'a pas des moindres
aux rentiers qu'avant mais on est
toujours quand même cette figure de
rentiers ai dû rentrer aujourd'hui après
il ya des choses qui ont changé la bon
jour notre équipe de bien aussi ont
sauvé avant beaucoup de pères
aujourd'hui c'est sûr ou de l'immobilier
ou du financier ou des biens
professionnels dans ton client donne on
a même parlé donc à plein de choses mais
il ya quand même aussi des permanences
par rapport à
ses nouveaux équipiers ils sont un
problème ou pas
je pense qu'il faut pas tous les mêmes
dans le même panier
on vous écoute et ans je pensais à la
typologie de l'impôt sur la fortune isf
au moment du passage à l'ifi et à
l'époque lorsqu'on regarde et on
s'apercevait que il y avait déjà une
première catégorie de contribuables
étaient riches qui avait un patrimoine
compris entre 1 million 3 et 2 millions
4 mais c'était 70% des redevables de l
isf et pour eux à 80% leur patrimoine
c'est d'immobilier principalement leur
résidence principale et puis pour les 30
% qui restent là on parle on commence à
parler de gens très riches c'est à dire
faire l'échelle française c'est à dire
des gens qui ont un patrimoine d'une
valeur nette supérieure à 10 millions 4
et plus vous êtes fortunés plus
corrélativement et ça semble a priori
assez logique plus la proportion de
l'immobilier dans votre patrimoine
diminue alors le problème c'est que on
se retrouve avec ses contribuables qui
ont entre 1 million 3 et 2 millions 4 et
qui sont avec leur résidence principale
qui surtout à paris vous l'évoquiez tout
à l'heure où on arrive vite à des
montants considérables pour des
appartements et puis on a ces 30% qui
sont des contribuables très fortunés
mais la particularité ces contribuables
ac qui vivent dans un monde ouvert
contrairement aux autres et lorsqu'on
vit dans un monde ouvert c'est pas
compliqué de passer quelques mois en
france quelques mois en belgique et puis
où
les donc ces contribuables très fortunés
généralement arrivera c'est ce qu'on
appelle le forum shopping multaq
shopping a échappé quand même en grande
partie à beaucoup d'imposition quant à
quoi ça ressemblerait un pays où on
aurait aboli l'héritage pesant 10
faisait allusion d'abord est ce que ça
existe
aujourd'hui
un peu ça ressemble avec ses avantages
et ses inconvénients
y aurait énormément de conséquence
abolir les laitages évidemment qu'en
parlant d'économie en fiscalité vous
avez ce qu'on appelle des réponses
comportementales donc les gens
réagissent à l'impôt les gens sont pas
là ou stupides et si vous augmentez la
peau des fortes chances que les gens
réagissent donc la supprimer
complètement l'héritage évidemment on
aurait potentiellement une évasion
fiscale très forte et à nouveau des des
conséquences en terme par exemple des
prêts d'immobilier aussi se dire que si
à chaque décès le bien été remises en
vente on aurait franchement voilà
beaucoup plus est des prix va une offre
beaucoup plus forts demo de biens
immobiliers une baisse des prix donc
avec plein de conséquences dans tout les
sens qui sera construit à mon avis assez
assez complexe assez complexe à analyser
ça serait intéressant c'est assez
complexe moche au final mais à nouveau
vous avez des pays donc si on tue on pas
aboli mais elle si je reprends l'exemple
tout à l'heure des états unis mais c'est
aussi la même chose pour le royaume uni
au même moment c'est des pays qui ont
plafonné l'héritage donc ses skis à se
rapprocher dans les faits pour un grand
pays sur longue période le plus 100 m 2
d'une abolition aussi là qu'on va
plafonner l'héritage à quelques on peut
mettre le second veut à quelques
millions d'euros et au delà de ça nous
vaut le l'état prend tout le reste est
ce qui fait que vous vous battez les
cartes aussi à chaque chaque génération
ça veut pas dire qu'après qu'ils
auraient plus d'inégalités on peut très
bien avoir des inégalités on a déjà
évoqué qui sont liées à nouveau à votre
salaire et par ses impôts là l'éducation
à la chance
mais ça serait des sociétés évidemment
assez différente c'est différent
derrière mais pas forcément souhaitable
à nouveau mon idée un peu sa vie les
séries tâches etc voilà de réguler
justement sur ces très grosses
successions
de rigoler un petit peu mieux et
justement le cas qui est évoqué pour
lier ça s'est jeté une preuve que l'idée
sèche marché n'était pas forcément bien
c'est le fait d'avoir un impôt qui
reposait sur les gens un peu brischoux
sur les images de la veuve par exemple
de lui dorée qui a vu sa dette à dix ans
après si c'est parce que personne n'a
finalement qui doivent payer aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'impôts sur la culture le
patrimoine comme quelqu'un qui ré hérite
d'un appartement à paris doit pas
aujourd'hui doit revendre le bien pour
eux pour le transmettre ce qui est
problématique c'est à nouveau des
personnes qui vont qui vont plusieurs
millions d'euros et qui vont mal allons
avoir plus plus de de patrimoine que
quelqu'un
surtout les salaires sur sa vie donc
c'est soulever les mandats médias aucune
aucune volonté de supprimer totalement
pour tous non le patrimoine il y des ja
des propositions aujourd'hui justement
pour maximiser l'héritage a pas plus de
12 millions d'euros d'ailleurs c'est
exactement le chiffre qui a été donnée
mais est ce qu'il ya des pays où on
abolit à par le rss en 1917
au sein d'union européenne on a six pays
qui connaissent plus les droits de
succession l'autriche oui ça d'accord
vous mais moi je parlais de l'averse
supprimer les supprimer
là bas je suis déformé par mail mais
ma connaissance non non ça existe
peut-être dans certaines dictatures
mais non en chine on hérite oui je
réfléchis en vous écoutant mais j'ai pas
d'exemples qui me vient comme ça
spontanément l'esprit non et
effectivement et ceux qui ont aboli les
droits de succession vous en parliez
tout à l'heure il n'y a que des
avantages d'après vous
dans le cadre d'une réforme globale du
système fiscal oui pour moi ça présente
de gros avantage il faudra aller voir ce
qui se passe si on regarde lui ne
serait-ce que l'union européenne sur les
28 états on en a six qui ont qui ne
connaissent plus les droits de
succession kim et 11 et qui ne les ont
jamais connu on à la suède dont je
parlais tout à l'heure on à l'autriche
la lettonie l'estonie la république
tchèque la slovaquie ces états là ne
connaissent plus les droits de
succession
mais pourtant pour autant est-ce que ça
veut dire que tout fonctionne
parfaitement ça c'est une autre histoire
il faudrait quand même se pencher
beaucoup plus sérieusement sur la sur la
question et et raisonner de façon de
façon globale et surtout de
de façon dépassionnée parce que c'est
difficile en france enfin notamment en
france mais surtout en france c'est
difficile d'avoir un débat serein et de
raisonner de façon pragmatique lors dès
qu'on parle de fiscalité et plus
particulièrement d'impôt sur la fortune
ou de droits de mutation à titre gratuit
alors comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure au regard du budget de l'état ça
ne représente pas grand chose mais
c'était vraiment des sujets clivants est
symbolique mais c'est d'autant plus
intéressant c'est que les français
étaient hors d'eux lors de leurs gonds à
l'idée qu'on supprime l'impôt sur la
fortune par exemple en revanche ils
veulent absolument pas qu'on touche
l'impôt sur les successions ils veulent
surtout pas que ça augmente quand bien
même la plupart d'entre eux n'en payent
pas de toute façon et que de toute façon
c'est une minorité qui hérite c'est une
minorité guérite mais comme le disait
fort justement nicolas frémaux il y en a
toute une typologie de contribuables le
gros problème que sas en matière d'impôt
sur la fortune ou en matière de droits
de succession c'est la résidence
principale
pourquoi ne pas exonérer purement et
simplement d'impôt sur la fortune et de
droits de succession la résidence
principale est celui qui a le château de
versailles est celui qui a un studio
j'entends bien mais c'est pas la
majorité du genre quand même nicolas
frémaux oui bader des arguments défi
kényan en avance et je veux transmettre
mon bien mais notamment la maison de
famille dans lequel il ya beaucoup de
souvenirs etc c'est vrai que c'est un
élément qui est assez important et c'est
surtout c'est ce qui se constitue le
gros du patrimoine de deux classes
moyennes et classes moyennes supérieures
dont 6,6 voici si vous protéger
davantage ce genre de bien c'est ça que
vous pouvez sûrement améliorer
l'adhésion à l'impôt est vraiment ciblé
à nouveau les plus les plus aisés donc
aujourd'hui le problème c'est qu'on a un
système qui est pas à nouveau par des
différences entre les héritiers
aujourd'hui à héritage égal en fait
étant donné toutes les niches fiscales
qui a pour certains biens qui a pas pour
d'autres deux personnes qui hérite du
même montant peuvent se retrouver à
payer des impôts très très différent et
ça s'est compliqué en fait à faire
affaire faire comprendre les essais
s'accomplit très fortement l'adhésion
donc une personne qui reçoit de
personnes qui reçoit 500 mille euros sur
toute leur vie si la première l'a reçu
sous forme de donation dont cinq fois
cent mille euros ou par ce jugement une
entreprise avec le pacte dutreil ou
l'assurance vie très bien payé 0 et
recevoir plus que ça allait payer zéro
et une autre qui a seulement entre
guillemets une résidence principale qui
va lui être transmise en une seule fois
amélie beaucoup plus derrière et ça
c'est un principe qui paraît quand même
aberrant et kiki et qui est en cause et
je suis par l'accumulation de niche
derrière qui à nouveau on va pas vous
refaire des discussions mais qui peut
être visitée pour certaines pas du tout
pour d'autres qui sont en tout cas sont
très rarement évaluer ça crée un vrai
problème d'adhésion d'adhésion à l'impôt
je pense elle
la plupart en fait qu est-ce qu il ya
beaucoup de monde qui est rindt
en france oui parce que toute façon si
vous n'avez pas d'enfants
ensuite ce sont vos frères et soeurs qui
vont hériter vos parents et puis si vous
n'avez pas de phases si vous n'avez plus
de frères et soeurs ou pas de faire des
séries de passes et plus de parents eh
bien on va on va remonter encore plus
loin et puis on a quelques successions
qui effectivement sont dites en
déshérence et qui sont recueillis par
l'état mais c'est loin d'être là mais il
ya toujours quelque chose on laisse
toujours quelque chose derrière soi oui
un certain losc ne laisse que des dettes
mais il laisse quelque chose quand même
allez encore une fois ce n'est pas la
majorité du jeu du genre la plupart des
gens laissent quelque chose mais compte
tenu du jeu des abattements souvent
c'est en ligne directe c'est la raison
pour laquelle il n'y a pas de droits de
succession qui sont payés mais en ligne
collatérale on l'évoqué tout à l'heure
entre frères et soeurs alors il ya une
niche fiscale qui fait que dans certains
cas le frère ou la soeur survivant peut
être exonéré mais c'est assez marginal
entre frères et soeurs le taux est de 35
à 45% ses 45 % au-delà de 24 mille euros
donc on y arrive relativement rapidement
entre parents jusqu'au quatrième degré
ses 55% et entre personnes non parentes
ses 60% et donc là on peut s'interroger
finalement sur le
le bien fondé de ce taux il ya une chose
que souvent les gens ignorent maintenant
alors il ya des différences d'un point
de vue s'il bien évidemment mais quand
on regarde les différents modes de
conjugalité le mariage le pacs ou
concubinage
la plupart des gens font pas la
différence entre les trois ors d'un
point de vue fiscal vous l'avez dit
nicolas frémaux l'a dit tout à l'heure
depuis la loi tepa de 2007 le conjoint
survivant et pacsés sur et grands sont
exonérés purement et simplement droits
de succession même si vous êtes marié
deux jours avant le décès de dupré
décédé bon par contre le concubin lui
même si vous vivez avec votre concubin
depuis 40 ans le concubin survivant en
plus n'a pas de vocation d'un point de
vue c'est lui donc il faut rédiger un
testament et en prime il va payer 60 %
de droits de succession donc voyez on
peut s'interroger finalement sur ces
discordances et hiatus entre la façon
dont s'est ressentie par le grand public
et la façon dont cette appréhender tant
par le droit civil que par le droit
fiscal là il ya des vraies différences
des vraies inégalités sont dernière
question les français ont découvert au
moment de la mort de johnny hallyday qu
en france on ne pouvait pas d'airé
vérité ces enfants mais qu'ailleurs on
pouvait
là aussi c'est pareil c'est la famille
c'est sacré ça a l'air d'être plus
sacrés en france qu'ailleurs c'est
incroyable qu'on puisse pas déshériter
ses enfants quand on y pense oui là vous
avez des différents systèmes d'un pays à
l'autre ou le srpt la quotité disponible
pour la liberté de tester donc le rôle
du testament on peut être très
importante dans certains pays est très
marginal et c'est le cas de la france
dans d'autres et en fait c'est pour ça
que vous avez toujours un fantasme
notamment dans les films les séries par
exemple sur l'ouverture du testament et
qui va recevoir tout l'argent en france
en fait c'est pas du tout ça que vous
pouvez jouer à la marge alors vous avez
quand même des moyens finalement de
favoriser un des enfants en passant par
l'assurance vie ou en passant comme
parrain par le testament mais ça reste
assez assez magique marginal en effet là
l'idée c'est que c'est une panne
vraiment une question à nouveau plutôt
philosophique et économique c'est de
dire on doit privilégier la famille dont
le conjoint elle ses congés en tête
pendant longtemps il était vraiment
laissé de côté au moment des successions
c'est assez récent ce rôle cas le
conjoint survivant mais pendant
longtemps c'était donc les enfants les
enfants d'abord et c'est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui n'a
pas changé en france depuis la
révolution française égale autre élément
qui est assez important aussi c'est de
garantir en fait l'égalité entre les
hommes et entre les enfants donc de
faire que les fils et les filles par
exemple reçoivent le même héritage et à
ce qu'on sait aussi c'est que dans la
pratique ça a été montré notamment par
sybille gollac et du bestiaire dans la
pratique en fait on peut quand même
malgré tout l'attirail les gammes qui
est censé garantir l'égalité quand même
générer des inégalités mais beaucoup
moins évidemment que aux états unis et
dans d'autres pays où là le testament
est roi et donc on peut complètement
donné tout son argent à l'hectare de la
famille wars un seul des enfants par
exemple et ne rien laisser dans les rues
aux autres avec des oui mais sait on est
on est passé finalement depuis quelques
décennies d'une dimension familiale une
dimension individuelle fait la famille
s'est rétréci la plupart du temps ça se
résume au au conjoint ou partenaire ou
concubin donc s'il ya ce mouvement qui
dit mais finalement mes enfants que j'ai
voit plus depuis des années est-ce que
qu'est ce qui justifierait que je sois
obligé de leur transmettre une fraction
non patrimoine et puis il ya aussi ce
souci de famille de maintenir les biens
dans les familles ça c'est un choix de
société un squale société et puis le
respect de l'égalité en théorie entre
les cohéritiers et notamment entre les
enfants alors bien évidemment il ya tout
un tas de stratagèmes je vais pas vous
donner de trop mauvaise idée mais qui
permettent de contourner plus ou moins
la réserve on a évoqué parmi les plus
courants l'assurance-vie
lusage de la quotité disponible il ya
bien d'autres stratagèmes et vous
faisait référence à johnny hallyday je
crois qu'il a essayé avec plus ou moins
de succès surtout moins que plus de lait
de les mettre en oeuvre mais je connais
pas très bien le jeu tu as fait mais au
delà de dépôt ya toujours possibilité de
contourner la loi on le sait mais mais
c'est plus la philosophie qui anime qui
anime
le législateur l'état et surtout la
france pourquoi est-ce que la france
dans ce domaine acheté le choix de
privilégier alors l'égalité entre les
enfants et ça c'est certainement à
l'origine d'une structure familiale qui
sont ainsi et qui sont différentes c'est
un héritage de la révolution de 1789 ou
même derrière des francs bien sûr la
volonté de
deux morceaux les le maximum les
successions pour éviter que se
reconstituent des batteries moines de
plus en plus important au fil des
générations c'est un choix de société
hilco à fresno oui bon bah y'a vraiment
plusieurs systèmes en effet pendant
longtemps en france vous aviez un
système de primogéniture c'était
l'enfant est né dans que le garçon est
né qui pouvait tout recevoir vous aviez
dans différents systèmes en fonction de
la loi sru vrai choix une vraie
transformation qui a été instaurée au
moment de la révolution je mens 2 789 on
a instauré une égalité au sein de la
famille et après l'autre chantier
justement c'est de savoir à ce qu'ils
ont instauré aussi une égalité entre les
familles beaucoup de débats au monde la
révolution là dessus ce deuxième débat a
été laissé de côté mais on a gardé en
effet une égalité au sein de la famille
c'est vraiment un choix en effet sur
laquelle est la famille quelle est la
vision qu'on a qu'on a de la famille en
france on a une forte préférence pour
cette famille nucléaire donc les enfants
avant tout le conjoint plus tard dans
l'histoire clairement un choix qui est
assez casse est clair que la france
n'est pas le seul à le faire mais en
fait on était assez assez fort
est ce que les femmes héritent autant
que les hommes dans notre pays
dans la loi oui parce qu à nouveau par
exemple mais dans la réalité
dans l'aridité pas le problème d'avoir
des statistiques en effet récente ça ne
dépend de tout un tas de choses donc
quand on fait la déclaration devant son
hôtel renaissance est justement donné si
vous avez un fils et une fille donner le
même le même patrimoine à ses deux ces
deux individus dans les faits à nouveau
un ce qui était montré par céline
bastien si big mac c'est qu'on pouvait
très bien aux contours n'est la loi
notamment quand vous transmettez un bien
professionnel donc une ferme par exemple
un commerce à aux garçons par exemple
qui va être le repreneur le garçon doit
racheter en fait la part de sa soeur et
on peut très bien donner une valeur
amoindrir en fait cette part est la
compensation est moins forte et dans ce
cas là sur le papier les deux séries de
la même chose mais dans les faits la la
chine dans une famille comme ça
hypothétique c'est le fait d'avoir
hérite beaucoup moins donc est ce que
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
très fréquent c'est dur de savoir parce
que le livre de mes collègues
propositions notamment quelques cas
d'entretien donc est ce que est ce que
c'est généralisable c'est compliqué mais
en effet on peut contourner la loi on
peut très bien avoir des femmes qui ont
mérité un peu moins même si dans les
faits je te demande dans les
statistiques fiscales ça va sembler
semblait également fait une question qui
est très complexe est intéressante mais
est assez complexe évidemment à répondre
à trazegnies frais avec donald était en
valeur et non par nature s'éveille si
effectivement vous avez un fils et une
fille pour reprendre votre exemple et
que vous souhaitez que ce soit votre
fils qui reprennent l'entreprise si on
reste dans les schémas classiques et les
stéréotypes et bien on peut faire en
sorte que la fille reçoivent autant mais
qu'elle ne reçoive qu'en numéraire en
fait on aussi toujours le cas de la
corse où les femmes et rite aid et des
terrains qu'on trouvait sans intérêt à
savoir au bord de la mer et qui sont
révélés très très très très avancés
américains au départ
c'était à l'arbre pensant que ça vaut
moins d'intérêt que la normale
je vous remercie tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]